-Newly unearthed texts
from the phone
of Donald Trump's
former chief of staff
have revealed that many
of the key plotters
behind the coup attempt
on January 6th
were sitting members
of Congress,
some of whom called for Trump
to use martial law
to stay in power.
The revelations come as
the January 6 committee
prepares to make
criminal referrals
to the Justice Department.
Oh, and Trump teased
a major announcement
that ended up being
a major dud.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump has been bizarrely quiet
the last few weeks,
which is suspicious given
he's supposedly
running for president
of the United States.
But then yesterday,
he posted an image of himself
in a Superman style costume
with laser eyes and the text,
"America needs a superhero.
I'll be making a major
announcement tomorrow."
Now, this led
to wild speculation
about what he was going to do.
Maybe it had something to do
with his presidential bid
or the mounting
legal woes he's facing.
Or maybe he was about to unveil
a chintzy knockoff
superhero doll
your grandmother would buy
at a dollar store for Christmas.
"But Grandma,
I wanted Deadpool!"
"This is even better.
It's Braindeadpool."
[ Laughter ]
"The guy at the store told me
it was just as good."
But when Trump finally posted
his major announcement today,
it turned out to be
so much more pathetic
than anyone could have
possibly imagined.
♪♪
Hello, everyone.
This is Donald Trump,
hopefully your favorite
president of all time --
better than Lincoln,
better than Washington --
with an important
announcement to make.
I'm doing my first official
Donald J. Trump
NFT collection,
right here and right now.
They're called
Trump Digital Trading Cards.
These cards feature some of
the really incredible artwork
pertaining to my life
and my career.
It's been very exciting.
-That IS very exciting.
[ Laughter ]
I bet Lincoln's
super [bleep] jealous
he didn't think of that.
But, real quick, which part
of your life and your career
is sunglass astronaut?
'Cause I feel like
I would've remembered that.
Also, got to love the timing
of a former president
launching his NFT line
the same week a crypto scammer
gets arrested.
[As Trump] They got SBF.
Looks like there's
an opening available, then.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] I'm also certain
Trump didn't look
at the copy of his script
until the cameras were rolling,
as evidenced
by this line reading.
-Each card comes with
an automatic chance
to win amazing prizes,
like dinner with me.
I don't know if that's
an amazing prize,
but it's what we have.
-[As Trump]
It's what we have, you know.
Is it the best prize?
It's not.
But, you know, it's Christmas.
And on Christmas, isn't what
we have enough, you know?
Because one day
you're president,
and the next day
you're selling a product
you don't fully comprehend.
[ Laughter ]
But who needs an iPad
when you can have a...
whatever the [bleep] this is?
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] And then
the ad ended with this.
-Remember, Christmas is coming,
and this makes
a great Christmas gift.
-No, it doesn't.
I don't care if you're the
biggest Trump fan in the world.
If, on Christmas morning,
you give your spouse
a thoughtful gift
in a beautifully wrapped box
with the bow on it
that they get to open and
physically hold in their hands,
and then they turn around
and tell you,
"Your gift isn't here --
it's a digital trading card
of Donald Trump
as a sunglass astronaut,"
you're getting a divorce.
[ Laughter ]
This proves once again
that for anyone involved
in the attempted coup
on January 6th,
things will not end well.
In Trump's case,
he's now such a pariah,
he's hawking scam
digital trading cards
on a social media site
no one's heard of.
Others may face jail time or
lawsuits or lose their elections
or possibly their law licenses,
like in the case of former
Trump attorney Rudy Giuliani.
Today, a disciplinary panel
for the D.C. Bar Association
found that Rudy
had broken attorney rules
in trying to overturn
the election.
If the entire board agrees,
that means
Rudy could be disbarred.
Rudy already had to sit through
a disciplinary hearing
earlier this month,
which was held virtually.
And at one point in the hearing,
he admitted to a weird
wardrobe malfunction
when he thought
the camera was off.
Now, heads up --
The video quality is not great,
but it's still
definitely worth watching.
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
That's right.
For some reason,
Rudy accidentally had
two watches on the same wrist...
[ Laughter ]
...and didn't realize it
until he was already
in the middle
of a disciplinary hearing
to review his law license.
[As Giuliani] Done so soon?
But it's only two.
Oh, but two twice,
so that's four.
[Normal voice] Two watches feels
like one of those things
that would cause
your grandchildren
to sit you at the kitchen table
and start showing you brochures.
"What about this place, Pepaw?
Look, it has a pond with ducks.
You like ducks."
Anyway, I feel like that
can't exactly help your case
when you're trying
to keep your law license.
"Mr. Giuliani, do you feel
you're capable of performing
the duties as a lawyer?"
"I do."
"Okay, and are you aware
that you have a pair of pants on
where your shirt should be,
and a shirt
where your pants should be?"
"I was not, but, uh...
that would explain why
I keep poking myself in the eye
whenever I try
to scratch my butt."
I can't even wrap my head
around the logistics of this.
I could maybe see putting
a watch on each wrist.
But how do you put
a second watch on your wrist
without noticing the first one
that's already there?
I mean, maybe he's just trying
to get a new mobster name
to catch on.
[As Giuliani]
Check it out, fellas.
I guess you can call me
Rudy Two Watches.
[Normal voice] Nah.
We're just gonna keep
calling you Dumb Rudy.
[As Giuliani]
Hey, you better watch it.
You better watch it.
[ Beeping ]
Oh, hold on. That's my alarm.
Oh, and that's my second alarm
that's telling me
to turn my first alarm off.
[Normal voice]
So, Rudy is already...
[ Laughter ]
Rudy is already
facing consequences.
Meanwhile, the committee
investigating
the January 6th insurrection
has announced
that it will hold its final
public meeting next week
before releasing a full report
on the coup attempt
and making criminal referrals
to the Justice Department.
While it's unclear which names
will be on that list,
there are some that seem
more obvious than others.
-What may be the last acts
of the January 6th
Select House Committee.
Chairman Bennie Thompson
says the panel will hold
its final public meeting
next Monday,
where its final report
is expected to be approved.
The chairman says announcements
about criminal referrals
will be made on Monday.
-We're expecting the names
of the folks
who would be referred for
potential criminal prosecution
to the Justice Department,
as well as the rationale
for why they are being referred.
-Now, former President Trump
is expected to be
at the top of the list
for criminal referral.
-That's right.
Donald Trump is high on the list
of potential names
for criminal referrals.
Now, I don't know
if his name will be on there,
but if it's not, that would be
quite the letdown.
It'd be like if the finale
of "White Lotus" never ended up
getting around
to telling you who died,
the whole episode was just
Jennifer Coolidge going,
"Ohh, wow."
[ Laughter ]
"Wowwwww."
Which would honestly be great.
[ Laughter ]
This committee has been in
existence for a year and a half.
How could they not have
enough evidence at this point
for a criminal referral
for the guy
who incited the insurrection
in the first place?
Like, can you imagine
the committee
gaveling to a close
for the final time?
"Well, we've spent 17 months
painstakingly reconstructing
a minute-by-minute timeline
of the events that day.
We've tracked down Trump's
every movement.
We've documented
every communication he made.
We've corroborated
every connection
he had to the central figures
involved in fomenting
the deadliest attack
on American democracy
since the Civil War.
And we're just [bleep]
stumped, dudes."
[ Laughter ]
"Ohh, wow."
Congressman Jamie Raskin,
who is one of
the committee members
making decisions about possible
criminal referrals,
told Politico that all of
the members involved
have legal experience and are
looking at the case as lawyers.
Okay, but I'm guessing
law school final exams
aren't this easy.
This is like a $200
"Jeopardy!" answer
in a category called
Rhymes With Reason.
[ Laughter ]
Although maybe,
maybe they are that easy.
I mean, Rudy's a lawyer,
so it can't be too hard.
[As Giuliani] Good news, boss.
I passed the law school exam.
It was on the back
of a cereal box.
There was a watch inside,
but I already had one.
So now I wear both.
You know, like a normal guy.
That's why they call me
Dumb Rudy.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] The more
suspenseful question is,
who else will get
a criminal referral?
Because as we've learned
this week,
the committee is in possession
of secret text messages
from the phone of former Trump
chief of staff Mark Meadows,
and those text messages reveal
that many of the key organizers
of the attempt
to overthrow the election
were sitting members
of Congress.
-Nearly two years after
the January 6th insurrection,
thousands of previously unseen
text messages
are revealing the lengths
to which Republican lawmakers
went in their efforts
to overturn the 2020 election.
They show Meadows
in conversation
with at least 34 Republican
members of Congress.
-The trove of coup evidence from
powerful members of Congress
is in writing.
We made this to make sure
you understand
these are the people
who were texting Meadows.
Some of them --
They're not all the same.
Some of them were asking
questions, lobbing in ideas,
claiming that they were kind of
being an intermediary.
Others -- many of them,
and we have the receipts --
were actively cheering on,
demanding, or supporting
an illegal coup.
-So, 34 Republican members
of Congress
were texting Trump's chief
of staff to help plan a coup.
Did none of them think
they'd get caught?
I don't text anyone that freely
unless it's my weed dealer who,
for some reason I trust with my
name, address and phone number,
and to whom I feel
perfectly comfortable
texting things like...
And then he feels
perfectly free to text back...
[ Laughter ]
And the texts are,
as you'd suspect, very damning.
You may remember
that Georgia congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
was caught texting Meadows
about the possibility of Trump
declaring martial law
to stay in power
and misspelling
the word "martial."
Well, now we have evidence
that a second House Republican
was also urging Meadows via text
to declare martial law.
-Here is a text message
that was sent
to Donald Trump's White House
chief of staff, Mark Meadows.
It says, quote, "Mark,
in seeing what's happening
so quickly and reading
about the Dominion lawsuits
attempting to stop
any meaningful investigation,
we are at a point of no return
in saving our republic."
Exclamation point,
exclamation point.
"Our" -- all caps --
"...last hope is invoking
Marshall law.
Please urge to president
to do so."
This text message
was from a sitting member
of the United States Congress --
Republican Congressman
Ralph Norman of South Carolina.
-This is now the second sitting
Republican member of Congress
to text Trump's chief
of staff about martial law
and also to misspell
the word "martial."
[ Laughter ]
When you spell it like that,
it sounds like an old Western
your grandfather keeps
telling you to watch.
"You'll love it.
It's in black and white
and there's no women in it.
Now, does your TV
get Westinghouse?"
[ Laughter ]
If nothing else, watching these
people debase themselves
is yet another reminder
you cannot slink away
from Trump's movement
with your dignity intact.
Whether it's embarrassing
texts, scam NFTs,
or accidentally
wearing two watches.
If you serve Donald Trump
or try to help him
overthrow the government,
you will end up humiliated.
It may not be as satisfying
as seeing all of his accomplices
go to jail...
-But it's what we have.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]